Americans have had a century-long love
affair with AM radio but one of am's
most popular Outlets is in danger of
going extinct and now an unlikely Duo on
Capitol Hill is working to stop that CBS
News Transportation correspondent Chris
Van Cleave has more on the efforts to
keep the airwaves coming in loud and
clear through car radios
as you approach the mccluggage bridge
for nearly a hundred years wmbd has been
covering and talking about the news in
Central Illinois from 1470 on the am
dial but not anymore for drivers of a
number of new electric vehicles a host
of automakers have pulled AM radio
tuners from their cars saying the EV
batteries can interfere with reception
there's no coincidence that the first
two letters of America are am they've
been around a long time Greg Batten is
the Greg in the Dan and Greg show Heard
mornings on wmbd for nearly 20 years I'm
not worried that we can't adapt to those
changes but it doesn't help when you
yank away a few million radios and say
well those folks can't listen to you
ever he was there when a vicious ef4
tornado tore a 46 mile path through
Washington County Illinois killing three
and injuring 125 while causing 800
million in damage and sending debris as
far are as Chicago we were immediately
on the air and stayed on the air
non-stop for days there are nearly 4 500
AM radio stations across the country
heard by about 82 million people a week
the AM signal tends to reach further
than FM radio often stretching deep into
Rural America it is typically home to
news and talk radio if you take away the
AM radio from Cars what does that do to
your business the quick answer is I mean
it could be disastrous to our business
no question
Capitol Hill this month First Responders
argued AM radio serves as the backbone
of the nation's emergency alert system
our belief is that AM radio is a
critical source of information to our
citizens during a crisis when disaster
strikes no one should lose access to
this essential information because the
vehicle being driven does not have AM
radio our members view
that there are more options for
delivering content and alerts now in
vehicles than there ever were Scott
Schmidt from the trade Association
representing automakers told Congress
the vast majority of cars still have AM
radio and the decision to pull it from
some EVS was not made lightly this has
been something that manufactures
look at customer preferences very
closely and so they do a lot of market
research and try to determine what how
to deliver the most value to the
customers
but that drive to tune out AM radio is
prompting unusual bipartisan agreement
between the very liberal Senator Ed
Markey and the very conservative Senator
Ted Cruz you know it I I'm pretty sure
that's one of the signs of the
Apocalypse kidding aside they are now
co-sponsoring a bill to require AM radio
stay in vehicles if Elon Musk can brag
that he can send Rockets into space that
he should be able to figure out how to
keep AM radio in passenger vehicles AM
radio is is is the lifeline to people
who are in crisis so it's an integral
part of keeping Americans safe while
automakers call the proposed legislation
distinctly non-essential forward
reversed course dropping plans to remove
AM radio from all its new vehicles and
will return it to all 2023 EVS in the
coming weeks Ford's Donna Dixon is the
lead engineer for the electric Mustang
Machi we
talked and listened to our customers
just the customers telling us hey
there's some emergency broadcast
frequencies that still aren't available
it's important to us we said okay we got
it we turned it back on why take it out
at all it seems like it's not broke
don't fix it kind of problem and we'll
continue to watch it as we go forward to
make sure that it's available at a
charging station in Gilman Illinois an
hour outside of Peoria Maki owner Keith
rice is glad to hear it's staying I just
think there's too many things on AM
radio that people still use wmbd
something that's never far from Greg
batten's mind whenever that on air light
turns red for CBS Saturday morning I'm
Chris Van Cleave in Peoria Illinois
don't take away my AM radio I need the
fan I need John Sterling Susie Waldman I
see that's what I said WCBS Sports
things that are on AM radio yeah at
least that's what I might go to it for
totally when you don't have Sirius sorry
places know where there are tornadoes
and hurricanes people really depend on
that we've all covered those things and
you're tuning to here especially if
you're driving especially when you're
driving there's a world where serious
and AM radio and all these other things
exist right yeah